Speaker 1: More on this Christian nationalism,
this bigotry run amuck and using the Bible to
justify their bigotry. I played for you yesterday
a clip of Pastor Andrew Brunson at the National
Gathering for Prayer and Repentance, where
Kevin McCarthy prayed over a bunch of Congress
people who are literally crying and weeping
for forgiveness about the evils of America.
And there's a line in there that
Brunson uses talking about a millstone.
A Scripture in the Bible.
Matthew Chapter 18, I think.
Where Jesus says something. I'm going to
paraphrase. Not much of a Jesus quote, but you
forgive me. It's something about that. It's
better if you call us a child to sin or fall
away from from following Jesus. It's better
to have a millstone and a massive rock that
would mill wheat tied around your neck and have
you thrown to the bottom of the sea. Execution
that it's better for that to happen than for
you to cause a child to stray from Christ
and broncs and use that line. And to prove more
evidence, more points about Christian nationalism
being dangerous and this spiritual warfare element
and melding politics and religion. There's a
congressman, a state legislator in Oklahoma,
who just is introducing the Millstone Act.
And I want to read about that. The first I'll give
you the refresher. On Brunson and his prayer at
the National Gathering for Prayer and Repentance.
Speaker 2: I believe that we are in danger of
judgment as a nation, especially because we have
become the primary character of the world, and
particularly of youth and children. Our government
and corporations increasingly march under the
rainbow flag. We bully weaker and poorer countries
to come under that flag. Our universities train
millions of foreign students who return to their
countries with this ideology. Our social media and
entertainment companies make it attractive. They
promote. They normalize, celebrate immorality,
and there is no escaping them. As a blanket
the world. There are godly mothers and fathers
around the world who fear our influence.
Sometimes when I'm in a foreign country,
I want to fall on my knees and repent for what
we are doing to these countries, to these people.
Jesus said, Woe to the ones to the one who causes
others to send. And he underlines this, especially
in relation to the young. Whoever causes one of
these little ones to send. It would be better for
him if a millstone were hung around his neck
and he were drowned in the depths of the sea.
Speaker 1: He's low key in a milquetoast
way, talking about execution.
And again, you may think he's a fringe character.
You might think he's a nobody you've never heard
of. You might think he has no power other than
the influence of a congregation. But he influences
people who do have a say, the Congress people
in that room who prayed with him and over him.
And people like this legislator
in Oklahoma. David Bullard.
I'm going to read a little bit from Andrew
Seidel, wrote this piece talking about this.
And I think it's poignant and I hope that it
will illuminate some things for you if you are
not quite on board with exactly how dangerous and
present this threat is. The article here Christian
Nationalist Legislator introduces Anti-trans
Millstone Act, suggesting Biblical retribution
a Biblical Death Sentence in America. In 2023,
a legislator has proposed the Millstone Act,
which he openly confesses, quote, was named
in reference to Matthew 18 six. But whoever
causes one of these little ones who believe
in me to sin. It is better for him to have a
heavy millstone be hung around his neck and
that he be drowned in the depths of the sea.
America embraced the separation of church and
state as a core fundamental value precisely to
prevent religious despots from abusing government
power to impose their personal religion on all
of us. But Oklahoma State Senator David Bullard
is a Christian nationalist out to make Oklahoma
into a Christian state forged in the fires
of Oklahoma State Senator David Bullard's
violent Christian imagery. This bill is one of a
horde of anti-trans bills sweeping our country.
Bullard's bill purports to protect children
while threatening medical professionals. It
declares a state of emergency and bans gender
affirming care in the name of bollards. God,
as with other such bills, it dehumanizes and
demonizes trans people. Unlike other bills,
Bullard christened his with a biblical name
that threatens that promises violence and death.
Again, this is mainstreaming and you may live
in California or New York or Massachusetts or
here in Washington, D.C. and you say, I live
in a liberal area. This will never happen.
But there are hundreds of millions of Americans
who live in red states who are under the thumb of
despots just like this. If you think there
are no Democrats in Oklahoma who will be
under the thumb of this, you are wrong. If you
don't think there's millions of Democrats in
Texas where they will copy this, you're wrong.
Christian nationalist politicians have almost
nothing to offer their constituents other than the
bitter sectarianism of Christian nationalism. The
Republican takeover in Congress, which is focused
on petty retributions, pointless and performative
investigations and possibly cratering the global
economy, proves the point. Instead of doing good,
such politicians seek to strip women and
minorities of every protection, support,
aid, assistance and basic dignity and then
call themselves pro-life. They will gladly
enact policies that dramatically increase infant
mortality and thrust millions of children into
poverty while claiming to care about children's
health. They fetishize their guns marvelously,
clutching the instruments of the leading cause
of death for America's children with an unrivaled
passion. They rail against life saving vaccines
and masks and the scientific consensus behind
them. While the COVID pandemic is also among the
top ten killers of our children and then brimming
with arrogance and utterly lacking self-knowledge,
they have the gall to propose legislation that
amounts to a death threat against those who
would harm children. Another line from the Book
of Matthew comes to mind. You hypocrite. First,
take the plank out of your own eye. Andrew Seidel.
And if you think it's just fringe, just
a state guy, he doesn't really have much
influence or power over the rest of us. Think
again because Matt Walsh just yesterday.
The Daily Wire's Matt Walsh. Ben SHAPIRO is
little bearded lapdog. Called for the execution
of doctors who provide gender affirming care.
Speaker 3: Trump also says as he goes on to say
that the that he would direct the Department
of Justice to investigate hospitals,
pharmaceutical companies, doctors to find
out if they have been involved in a cover
up of the horrific long term side effects and
of gender transition, drugs and surgeries. Now,
the answer, of course, is that, yes, they have
been covering those things up as any genuine and
thorough investigation will clearly show, which is
why the next step under a Trump administration or
any Republican administration should be to arrest
the culprits, the hundreds and hundreds of them,
if not thousands of them, and throw
them in federal prison. Now, this
can't be a matter of simple fines and financial
penalties. I mean, that should be part of it.
But the only real recourse here, the only
semblance of justice, would be prison sentences,
very long ones. Now, if it were up to me, we'd
go further than that. As far as I'm concerned,
mutilating and castrating children should
be legally considered a capital crime,
and it should earn the prescribe penalty
for such crimes. But if we can't have that,
then prison will have to suffice.
Speaker 1: This is where we are in America in
2023. So I would assume there are many out of you
out there who are organizers, who are activists
who care about the direction that our country is
taking. And this isn't just about budget battles.
We are. This is not hyperbolic. We are in it for
the fight for the soul of our nation. Are we a
nation of equality and acceptance and diversity?
Or are we a country of white Christian nationalism
and oppression? That's the question. And are
you ready? Because it's only going to get
worse. Before it gets better. I'd love to have
you subscribe to our YouTube channel, Dallimore
Daily here on YouTube. You can find my podcast
anywhere podcasts are found. It's called I Doubt
It with my lovely, talented and scholarly co-host
Brittany Page. And of course, you can follow me on
social media and tell me how wrong I am. There I
am at Dallimore on Twitter, TikTok and Instagram.